And this video will motivate the design
of neural networks that are dedicated
for natural language processing problems.
So natural process,
natural language processing is a,
the field that concerns itself with any
problem or tasks that involve some sort
of language data. Uh, in the, uh,
this veto. In the following videos,
we'll actually focus on textual data,
uh,
so data from web pages or written
documents that have been converted into a
actual words like Ascii
characters for instance. Um,
speech processing is often considered
as part of the types of problems where,
uh, that NLP addresses, uh,
but it actually has its own
dedicated, uh, research community.
That's what our conferences,
just for speech processing and the natural
language processing conferences often
mainly concerned themselves and
concentrate on a textual processing.
And so in the following videos,
we'll mainly focus on that text data.
So much like for computer vision,
uh,
we could think about whether we
could design neural networks that are
specifically designed for solving
a text processing problems.
And one particular a specificity of
textual data that we'll want to take into
account with design neural networks in
order to design better neural networks
for textual data is the
fact that as we'll see,
text data is inherently high dimensional.
Uh,
the words that will be manual
relating for performing certain, uh,
tasks, uh, we'll see that
intrinsically a priority.
They are very, very high dimensional
objects and manipulating dose,
uh, in a naive way in the neural
network can lead to some problems.
And so there have been
solutions for, uh, the,
this particular high
dimensionality problem for an
LP that had been introduced.
And, uh, as we see in the following
videos, we'll see how to leverage, uh,
and directly address the
high dimensionality of words.
And then it will be problems
for many different tasks.
So we'll see that in the following videos.